vous avez sûrement envie de savoir ce
qui se passe dans votre corps un
lendemain de cuite bah il faut aller
chercher la réponse du côté de notre foi
c'est lui qui est chargé d'éliminer 90%
de l'alcool qu'on s'envoie et il lui
faut environ 1h30 pour éliminer un verre
une fois dégradé par le foie l'alcool se
transforme en acétaldeïd une substance
toxique et cancérigène en plus elle est
responsable de symptômes comme les maux
de tête les nausées les vomissements ou
les tremblements et c'est encore au foie
qui revient la tâche d'éliminer c'est
assez taldéhyde mais le problème c'est
qu'il n'est équipé que pour en traiter
une toute petite quantité quand on boit
de l'alcool notre organisme demande
aussi un petit effort à nos reins pour
chasser l'intrus ils élimine plus d'eau
que d'habitude c'est pour ça qu'on fait
plus pipi oui parce qu'on urine plus de
liquide qu'on en boit en réalité et du
coup le corps va puiser dans ses
réserves d'eau personnelle et notamment
dans celle du cerveau et ça s'applique
cette déshydratation est notamment
responsable des maux de tête mais aussi
des crampes musculaires autre
responsable du malaise des substances
chimiques qu'on appelle les congénères
et qui viennent de la fermentation de
l'alcool ou qui sont ajoutés dedans
artificiellement pour finir sachez que
si l'alcool aide à s'endormir il
détériore sérieusement la qualité du
sommeil c'est ce qui explique la fatigue
extrême et la confusion les jours de
gueule de bois